le site Esso exon mobile de Fos-sur-Mer
toujours à l'arrêt ce matin 22e jour de
grève rassemblement dans le calme
encadré par une discrète présente
policière même chose à la raffinerie
totale énergie de La Mède ici la grève
initiée par la CGT pour des
augmentations salariales en état son 15e
jour on ne lèvera pas les grèves sur mon
site pour rentrer en négociation et si
on augmente les salaires on augmente
donc les coûts de gestion de la boîte et
donc le produit à la fin devient plus
cher et donc c'est pour ça
en fait en 83 jusqu'en 83 le salaire
était indexé sur
83 ça a été arrêté par Pierre Mauroy
parce que c'est un cycle qui
effectivement n'est pas vertueux on peut
remercier nos danseurs le bonhomme
Cetelem qui était avec nous je vous
appelle pour un petit crédit à la conso
je vous appelle dans une heure la galère
pour trouver du carburant l'angoisse de
rouler sur la réserve des internautes
réagissent à la pénurie de carburant
avec humour on voit ressortir la carte
citerne des sens du jeu des mille bornes
[Musique]
découvrez vite le 1000 Bornes édition
2022 pour des heures de fun
de naissance fin décembre fin de
l'essence fin de naissance fin de
naissance
[Musique]
d'autres pensent déjà à Noël et pourquoi
pas offrir un plein d'essence on m'a
raconté une blague sur les sens et
jerricané des blagues il y en a malgré
cette nouvelle pénurie qui ne touche pas
tout le monde j'ai de l'essence de la
moutarde et une ps5 dans cette station
essence parisienne le litre dépasse les
deux euros 50 ou carburant confondu
pourtant pour la plupart des clients le
coût n'a presque plus d'importance
actuellement même si la lutte me coûtait
5 euros j'ai pas le choix je suis obligé
de le prendre ambiance angoisse quoi
Enzo tu veux boire un truc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je m'en bats les couilles
[Musique]
c'est bon
vous arrêtez là c'est bon ça sert à rien
de râler
tout le temps
[Rires]
dans le Val-d'Oise c'est une information
RMC une station-service a été
réquisitionnée par des délinquants à
Villiers-le-Bel ils ont pris le contrôle
en filtrant eux-mêmes les clients et en
vendant leurs propres carburant à leur
tarif la police s'est intervenue à un
homme a été interpellé non
policiers partout vous nous prenez pour
des enfants
voilà on est considéré comme un enfant
on voit que ça fait énormément
personne en France du respect que les
queues que ce soit les queues de cinéma
et que dans les magasins c'est une ça de
manière générale on respecte pas les
tues ça on le sait Virginie merci
beaucoup Janine a raison ça sert à rien
ça sert à rien mais oui autant rester
positif et il vaut mieux avoir une
petite bougie que de râler dans le noir
ils sont
en train de faire poubelles alors c'est
pas marrant moi c'est la première fois
je la vois celle-là à chaque fois
[Rires]